- Ready.
- Sí.
Okay.
Once every four years,
the pursuit of football's grandest prize
for its grandest players.
What each intends to be
his journey of a lifetime.
Pressure?
Every player here feels pressure.
But this is a World Cup,
and it's really tough.
Every country has their stories.
Every player has their own narrative.
Everybody wants to win.
Only one of us will be happy
at the end.
Let's go win! Come on!
Let's go, boys!
I think it's important
that you control your emotions.
They're under enormous pressure.
When you have such a person,
everything is easier
when you step on the pitch.
What brings us together
in the end is Morocco.
He tells me, "Daddy,
there's something positive in this."
"What is that?"
"You're coming home."
Be ready to fight
in every second of the game.
Messi, goal!
This is the World Cup!
It's life or death.
Our planet unites
around its ultimate game.
We're going to fight.
- Netflix?
- Yes.
- I'm going to appear on Netflix, then?
You should have told me.
I'd have dressed better.